- So I hear you had a memorable moment,
though, with a famous musician.
This is the craziest story ever.
Is it, so it's right after
you got sober, right?
- Oh, I know, yes.
So, so on my podcast, "Literally,"
one of, one of the things that I love
is I get to not only just talk to
like people like Chris Pratt and Gwyneth,
and Oprah and just the biggies.
- Yeah.
- But I ask, get to talk to
people that I get to nerd out to,
that I don't know, like Jann Wenner
created the Rolling Stone.
He has a book out that's great.
I had him on, and I was talking about
when I got, we're both sober, Jann and I.
I got sober 32 years ago.
- That's awesome.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks.
- That's so awesome.
Yeah, here's another gee golly.
- I set my cap, and I got sober.
- Nice call back.
- That's right, yeah.
And so I was newly sober, and I was
backstage at a Rolling Stones concert.
And Keith Richards said,
won't you come back
to the hotel and party with me later?
And I had this, I was like,
okay, I'm either gonna
party with Keith Richards,
and not be sober.
Or I'm gonna turn down Keith Richards?
- Yeah.
- To go party with.
I'm 20, whatever it is.
And I remembered, I didn't do it.
But, it was one of those -
- Good for you,
'cause that's hard.
Because you know what though?
If you turned down something that rad,
you knew that you needed to
make a change in your life.
- Yeah yeah, exactly.
- You know that,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, for sure.
- And that's actually a good point.
- I felt really good.
I felt like if I could do
that, then I was gonna be -
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)